on mais qu'est-ce que je mens car moi
j'ai même à crémaillère à faire
j'aimerais bien affaire est bon je paie
pas la faire et va lui il va le faire
sous prétexte qu'il a de l'argent et
qu'est-ce qu'ils sont comme au pire
non mais alors rien n'est encore acquis
c'est dommage je veux dire je vais la
classe et pas de piste en herbe
d'arthrite et sous préfet de moselle
sous prétexte de jets de losail bas je
peux et si je passe au pire ils ont une
amende se traçant 35 euros la main ils
vont la payer or ils ont payé le menu
160 que vous dire qu'on prend pas ça
mais rien mais c'est pas vrai il n'ya
pas que les privilégiés qui resteraient
ctoire ya plein de resto tout à fait
normal ils ont raison de le faire
il ya plein de fait avec des gens
modestes qui vont ils ont raison de le
faire aussi brad là dedans et pierre
jean charles ans on le dit lui même
c'est l'absurdité de cette situation
donc tagil à la mise à la vie de gerry
la régie va faire tout à l'heure on
aurait dit un épisode de faites entrer
l'accusé donc oui servi des entrecôtes
et oui enfin c'est c'est absurde c'est
ça aussi la moralité de cette histoire
est ce que pierre changeux jean
chalencon dit c'est que c'est
complètement absurde
on en train d'accuser des gens parce
qu'ils ont mangé moi ce qui me gêne
après après qu'ils fassent des d'y aller
déjà choix effectivement c'est choquant
mais la loi est la même pour tout le
monde nous sert moi je vous dis
franchement ici à cette table on est
plutôt tous à faire attention série ou
externe en fait moi j'ai pas de dîner
oui j'imagine pas de coupe à la maison
mais maintenant j'ai pas souhaité
bouleverser non mais sans rire tout le
monde fait des mines et vous j'ai pas de
copain répond raymond fait attendre en
fait tous un peu attention et lui dit
impunément
oui bah oui j'en ai marre je vais je
fais dit demain 15 mai nous aide d un
avocat de chance si c'est à cause de
mecs comme ça si c'est à cause de mes
copains
qui nous représentants du moi je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec benjamin
d'ailleurs moi même personnellement
j'arrête je fait extrêmement attention
j'ai même dû dire à ma fille de partir
de ce qu'elle a 18 ans et elle rentrait
tous les soirs à 2 heures du matin à 3h
du matin donc j'ai chopé ma fille j'ai
fait ici t'es chez moi que tu as 18 ans
ou pas je suis désolé on en plein kovy
jours donc la raison si tu n'es pas de
la raison parce qu'il ya ton père
quelque 71 ans et c'est très grave
oui mon frère il peut le chopper aussi
espérer pas en classe et tous enfin
heureusement et ma fille est faible
agissements je fais ce que je dis ok bah
tu te démerdes tu vas chez une copine ou
tu te prends un appartement j'ai dit
c'est carrie également isabelle avec six
mois bien qu'à 72 en général et pas les
hôtels restaurants ici alors je te le
dis non